don't even know what a bubble tea is  that's absolutely not healthy okay great  we could've gotten a milkshake  dude that's really good  uh yeah i guess but this is a treat i  mean this is too much this is for  children  i tell you my succession story that's  how i auditioned for it what i never  told you this no i don't think so so you  said the episode worth the retreat in  the stand-up comic it's pretty poorly  written yes i remember going in being  like i want this i feel like there's  like a hacky comic i threw a blazer and  a t-shirt on went in beautiful and  they asked for my avails  which means i think my agent was like i  think you might have like what was with  hillary at the time she was like i think  you i think you got this yeah they asked  you around next week oh my god and then  so she was like that i think they want  you and i was like  this is my favorite show get me on and  then and then they went uh nori davis he  was that he was very good